j'aimerais que vous mettiez deux bouts
et que tu fasses une blague debout
devant victoria à la pro b elle échoue
j'ai le vertige et démarrer la voiture
qu'est ce qu'on m'a dit des battles pas
te raconter une blague c'est le concept
de l'émission
à côté une petite tu fais une belle
épine c'est un mec
ces deux mecs qui passent permis de
conduire il arrive à l'auto école mais
ça a permis de conduire à l'ancienne
c'est très perturbant conduire à
l'ancienne c'est à l'oral il passe le
code donc le premier qui rentrent le
jury lui dit écoute c'est par exemple la
priorité à droite il dit moi je la
laisse pas c'est très bien ce rouge dit
je m'arrête pas distrait bien d'y et le
stop stop jamais je m'arrête au stop
tout récent sauf que le deuxième il a
tout entendu iran qui dit l'onu pose la
même question alors priorité à droite et
priorité à droite je m'arrête pas gabon
au feu rouge je m'arrête pas aux feux
rouges et le stop dit je m'arrête pas au
stop
il est bas vous avez perdu permis de
conduire et qui prouve devait accepter à
l'autre n'est pas ce que l'autre est
passé permis de conduire de l'ambulance
[Applaudissements]
tu vas côté une à bouder osirak août
qu'est ce que tu racontes ya là haut
c'était
un anglais c'est avec nous qu'on peu
après
[Applaudissements]
mais je vais faire dans la pharmacie est
lente et les déjà pu soit un paquet de
bahia guardia gras oui on connaît ça
c'est pour le jeune
le pharmacien demain mais monsieur vous
avez besoin explique comment des
prescriptions de brut us voilà elle dit
mais malheureusement j'ai pas mais
j'aime photos de ma femme bouder tu peux
pas relate amap se blesse